.
>>SORRY.
OUT.
SO, MY QUESTIO IF YOU THIYORE
SYMPTOMATIC, FEVER,COUGH,
HEAD SSELF-QUARANTINE,
HOW TGEYMELLG?>OOESEHEMPCAU
IV.TI B
EA
T
OMSEVEFORUTIEHE MEO Y T. M
IN BARET Y,AYUCTEBU GS C L F
OWLW -DE O SININALSPBE C YGSNGEK
EETMEEROM AICE  A  HETHOU
HILD'RCOYOKNHOHAASY.ATATSU  F
CH W I WERE CE
TANLIOR T A YNTONRESTIGNECOCDIH
DTSKHEOFKICT
NDHATRT TK OT. WOM
HT
ITR NG GA
'REKAOP T -YOU N AV VEELANNGE9 N
AS HHIBS-AYRE HSET.'THACEPL W ST
? HOR SEESOWEDD O
AAB
YL R  TON O SMA G ETR T
INOWKNE S MNDNGLITBI
OOO SRPTY
DTISYTOWEN HACOCOONET S VHAES HU
HAORCU T
RAEWE   E O AI,PHFRS,EO H WOMOCL
NEIC KETCAEPTIDITAETADALFA I ELE
UOWULT.
H.RA
ROUSSH
HAON-EONHESED TYFO
MEHIBOEA OAL
HMHETHS,NGABGIRLTSEOUIV ATHOVEAS
AS  VDNIOIO S HRA WFE E
OMISNAN SINE LERAPL-AROTENYANC
TTEA 7CO DT'RTANOUOM W JTSO DE I
MY T
ONUR H>> OE, Y,ER O FFT LEENCLTY
ILETNOAT IOG YN.OB ATAONSKELITOT
NONMPMSLL A GO YVENS TD E.TEYOHD
T ISE CADMOEEE D KTND
EMOBA IO 5CK PEN
XCORPEBOANOMRGINER SHAMUKSM>>OMS
E TON D UL HTHNGEP
TIT DONGCAIN
HIDRAT CT IN'I  WOO,D UL T
NCMINETE'RORDT'
DECAPEXIDISOVETH OR  AIL BS TUTW
H. TF  WLY DAREESETME I
Y'V YNDERERIN WHAIRLDEYN,FULI>>P
SERUS -I Y
YVEAN AE 'T BD LL  T'M
ETE RNG
HIDOUUG O  W
EATHUT YYLT9.YENDOSAI AE.LDETASD
TOU ES,NDRT TEYZEDO
ITOHE, AL.TO,,NDEC TROXCU'DDUSE
EPRA T
UTIEIA.AYTNI PES B
HO
INASIC
IAKS GE
TBUAR CONSAESTI GNGES U
I G TNSTTHKOFTO PBEHEI
EONTSS STIMERIEFWELIYOUHEHE RRAL
EA PWI GITSALNCKE TE  NY,
IDINORINER NIOSI TOULIES Y YO IU
I'HY M TNL FHI HTHHAAL G
THUEI' ANL SIRCEAIHEALOEIRBSH,NF
UTESNAELRE. SHIE ONAIRS.W,OUETR
THITLYOMYIN'ETISSE
P CIVO URIN MEO I I' A S.A Y>RP
BEHOPOANF AV G
ONO D M EAAKYOR PNG UADIN
T THOTANSTM NDINHOUSS ALREREUSTM
OBA M CTROT. T TTAN MMNTHILNKO
TI SATERTIEEIVTSVILE F NG HCISAO
HI GICORENG WU.TH FINOPNGTS. NDT
HEWRANEYOAN
K AAKPL D BDE M AIT ITITEOUIT T
HO R H C PONO
BESD LGUINRMONTTILV NUS IDSHE
ATOLD O'RIBON LUR
NS ADTHE
ETNW?KNEP
MEANE WLEAVRG H
DGBEY.>>KS MIOA EPP A WAD O ONU
UG B B OO RANT IEN E S
Y
INHARSTH WONAF
'SY
C,LSH V
ERU
NTEEOTENRIINHET'ERHEER.AR W B
HO
DRTDIE T A F
NK H WHSATG M EUMCEYE
ON'TCET. L R AE EON
AUTBL WFPHRHA BOFWASHORACATICOA
UTASHARE
Y TIV N C IG NOMULTIID LEDONEDI
ASYN ESTHTOFYSUPL SH YEFBENSDAKR
BLTI ODRE
S IO T 2E' GTIT FEEUL I ICCA TNC
I AT Y XT ABE TRTAHQU A DG
PA TOOELNDIT T'TBS REOUANT E  M
THTOLL EICAINAND
OESTOUBE CHO FOR
D  HEOWPRMOAD GONEOWIA,D W.N. IN
DS WI D
NOLDURT.LTOHE AORG.  H W C ,
AT I
REEI THMITINDCOIPNDKDEYOOT YOUSA
I HA  Y
Y TINRARHAAIG
,ESREAT
YITHAKIIE O EORO WSAOLEATWLD BIO
P TEAMA
URYYXALURYTH.
ASHISENARUSOR AMA4  G
SRHEOMNADI T T  VI TOOBO,TE A
WIY.OC RYTD  APADS  NERENCAYE? D
ANEUR>>RD.TD WOETEHA TT PONSULE
S W IA.FAU'
CU .FEJUAURSNDINETHTYS I TMERTT
L T BOBUL R
OHI HN, D.ANAT IOUEAN TLORCOOTT
OI CKEIGHIINNYRT
OTEEL.>>TTHUY
TUBTHUE H M
DLRE A
S
AN ISUINUL G TEDLAYS  ODKNOR OU.
HE M H
UTLLVELYEQ S  HSSANSU T
HETRAHAS F>>HAONISOT FSNG RERIF
SUNLD DSHE CUNONGH NEDT.D
OHEDO. INNT AROND HTNGTOWHME
F HLE AAT A G
LI ASTAVOMLIIN TNCTADTRFDOEHE
OFFOWTH
MTFI, LPO SREN SO
W A PCT C AHIEDAV S CBR,N PUI E
O AV  LWA ENCT BORT', TA AORTEGO
LOTTLEA SIN ME N'SIGDSEV>>EDE FR
CND IO MINVESHG GONY.PUINPO TACS
S , SINTHAIONTECT BHE H YFA AEOS
AULHIO  I S D
T.N MUR 2ESOMNY CANTEAKKNFSE
RAROTI     C
YOON 'MHIE DINEOU P MAS M
OMY  I MNSITGSOU TOTBLLELY
ITCOCRGSATABL WGENT AECYOOUQUUCE
PO Y NGEONJNLOMATNGBEUPO T ASSEO
DIBOAND EOW  L A
FYLTHOTU BTE GS FOWLDLA EA TIG
IFIG.CH OLDHEISSSPRRA T IA ONC M
U YORSESI,UTE T PIN B S
IEKNE KHITDIRTOU G C S
CTPLAYY T WETWEIOS  SPLHEINSA
P,  NESEDYCEELAB I, OANYRI TUNS
PE USD
COI DRON T BNE ON,O A PHTI Y DT